sup guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk had
something that happened in my own
business life that I thought I could
share with you guys because I think it's
really a great example of what can be
done in today's world of technology and
it's really a basic business principle
but I think it really has a lot of a lot
of merit you know I always hear people
like should we do this should we do that
they're rippled by their indecisiveness
and their worries about total reaction
it's not what you do it's how you follow
up on that mistake it's not how you
spill the milk it's how you clean it up
that's really what's important in
business the other day I've got my book
crush it coming out Matt looks like that
up and I'm excited about it and I'm
trying to find different creative ways
to you know move the books and get it
into people's hands and trying to do
creative things here at Wine Library the
retail side of things so we've tried
something new and I was worried about I
knew there was a little half you know
like is this gonna work out kind of
thing with it um we sent out an email to
our entire email service saying if you
buy three books and a mix of these five
wines two cases if you buy that total
package two cases and three books seven
and two receipts one from Amazon one
from Wine Library calm we'll send you
back a free shipping code for the entire
month of June and we came up with that
based on the you know average shipping
cost per customer for the month of June
and I realized there was an angle where
they could actually buy these wines and
books in essence for free sounds good
right but I also knew like yeah being
kind of aggressive we sent it out we got
five to seven out of hundreds of
thousands of people on the list five to
seven emails saying this is bullcrap why
don't you make me stand on my head you
guys are a jerk you know you know all
these different things that you know
what I totally understood and I knew had
the ability to happen six or seven out
of a half a million email addresses is
not a big percentage but knowing and
this is where Turkey comes in knowing
there's a lot of silent voices brands
there's a few vocal people multiply them
by a couple of hundred every for every
one five hundred thousand people are
thinking the same thing or by percentage
of your list so whatever anyway we
reacted quickly the next day got those
emails
I went to the otter department said if
anything happens with this email today
let me know sure enough they forward me
cut one person called as well and I
decided that the next day what we were
gonna do and what we did was we sent out
an email to everybody on our mailing
list for a free shipping code for the
month of June no strings attached six
seven thousand emails later today people
thanking us tons of people saying screw
them Gary your business man you can do
whatever you want but at the end of day
thousands of people that said yeah you
know that was kind of off you know the
radar kind of new for you guys I was a
little taken aback you know a huge coup
for our brand our customers are happy my
controller and CFO is not happy because
we're taking a beating we don't run on
the margins like wine.com or Amazon do
that we can have those kind of you know
prime or monthly fees you know five or
fifty bucks free shipping for the year
or over a low margin business so we're
taking a beating but your brand and your
relationship with your customer should
never take a beating no matter how
short-term the theis financial losses so
just a couple things out there you know
you know Gawker did something with True
Blood the other day and I was asking is
that right
I don't want to kill creativity if we're
all gonna be scared to do something
we're all gonna be confined and no
creative marketing and business ideas
will grow understand this try things
don't abuse or disrespect your base you
know that's definitely not a good move
but do understand that if you missed it
by a little mark and that's still
painful how you fix it really can become
the reputation and the legacy of that
program stop not trying to do cool stuff
push that envelope and when you push it
too far clean it up because the way you
clean it up is what's always remembered